in how the upper world is now understood
the opera world is only accessible
through love and it's love in this sense
that's now been completely divorced from
reason
and it's love as this driving of your
will to make assertions
yeah see even even you saying it it's
love in the sense that it's divorced
from reason yeah
i can only intellectually understand
when i say intellectually i just mean
i just as if i'm reading it like in
terms of
this implies this implies this i don't
i can't feel how reason can be
associated with love
sure well let's i mean so i'll point you
again to harry frankfurt and his
wonderful book reasons for love and and
even work by
reid montague the neuroscientist one of
the difference between us and computers
is we have to care about the information
we're processing and the computers don't
right and so this notion of caring
and the notion of love are really
central
because right if you
you can't which way should i start from
this i could
start from one side and work to the
other i could work either way so
let me let me try what what frankfurt
says right
i can't sort of reason about everything
i can't do that
right i i i have to there has to be
even if i'm going to do science there
have to be topics i
uh to use frankfurt for topics i take
seriously
things i care about this relates to
salience yes exactly
relevance realization is not called
calculation it's a you are
your brain is deciding you know
out of all the things that can pay
attention to which ones
it should commit it's very we pay
attention
which which you know which things it
should devote it's very
precious time and processing resources
too
out of all the things that could and
that's always risky because this not
might not be the right thing
so that is always deeply an affective
thing
it's never just an inferential
calculative thing
so if does dimasio's work on descartes
error
right if if you get people right they
have a brain damage
such the frontal lobes are working but
it's not connected to their emotional
center
you can give them like a calculative
problem and they can solve
massive calculation they have no problem
with that but you can
you you can you can you can destroy them
sort of in this way do you want to write
this problem in red ink
or blue ink right and so
right they start trying to compute yeah
all the possibilities and permutations
and you can't
you have to care and caring is like a
simplest a a
it's the core of love right it's
heuristic yeah yeah you used to simplify
it yeah well
and and and enable if you don't do this
and this is montague's point about how
we're different from computers
if you don't do this like you're going
to get commentary explosion of all the
facts and
permutations and possible combinations
you're going to have to expect and this
is related to the frame problem as well
yeah exactly
exactly exactly so right so
there's that aspect if you don't care
you actually can't reason
but it also i can go from the other poll
reason is
ultimately right it's got this and this
is i think one of the great platonic
insights
and this is how we should understand
that's why i corrected you one point
when i want to talk about rationality
and not just logic because logic is a
relationship between propositions
right whereas rationality is supposed to
be a relationship you have to reality
right and one of plato's great insights
is that in addition to whatever we
desire
we desire to be real we want it to be
real we want this goes back to what we
were talking about earlier we want it
part of what makes things meaningful is
we wanted
is that innate i don't know how
i don't know because i because after
listening to you and
watching some lots of your work i
question now how much of what i think is
innate is an eight so even this
you know you give the example of of who
wants who's in a
great relationship and then and then who
would want to know something that
undermines
that right and 95 percent of the people
say
i want to know okay so that means that
we want to be a part of this real world
we want to be connected to it yeah
and when people have these experiences
of mystical experiences they'll
transform their whole life and their
identity
because they want to remain close and
you know in consonance
you know even conformity identity with
this increased realness that they've
discovered so people will radically
change everything
just to stay in contact with realness
so yeah i think real now so is it a meta
drive
do i think plato's right i think we're
getting increasing empirical evidence
that plato's right
in addition to all the arguments that
plato already gave us is it innate i
don't know
i mean i think the i think relevance
realization abilities have to be
innate in some fashion because you have
to have them
in to some degree in place to get going
is does that
i i don't know i'm sorry i just so okay
so to recapitulate
it's a 12th century split between
so precipitated by the fact that now you
can read in your head
yeah yeah and then aristotle yeah which
is essentially science being
formed so imagine aristotle didn't exist
but you can just read in your head would
you think the meaning crisis would have
happened
um maybe but probably not slower
maybe a different history i mean going
back and trying to rewind history is
like that's a that's that's a really
difficult and tricky thing to do okay so
so it starts to split and then that
split just gets great and obviously
around 15 16th
the invention with newton galileo so
you've got the scientific revolution you
get descartes
right before that you have the
protestant reference
can you explain that which one
protestant referendum oh
um so i'm a scientist i'm familiar with
the descartes and well not actually much
familiar with data
but with newton and galileo you should
you should be familiar with daycare
because if you're a scientist you're
using graphs
yeah yeah that's that's cartesian that's
all i know that's a that's there's
another psychotechnology
invented by descartes and it really
imagine how much
more difficult it would be to do science
without cartesian graphing
right okay so anyways notice how often
these pivotal changes
are associated with changes in
psychotechnologies
uh so um so protestant reformation
um there's a there's a little
yeah okay so so
for for lots of various reasons having
to do with corruption that it's sent
into the church
there's because there's separation from
god
and and and and and oh and god's
becoming sort of more absurd yes
wait i just want to make sure that
because i'm just i'm trying to
understand so
the way that i understand is i'll
explain it and then i get corrected yeah
i understand so much better
so no no no that's lutheran i think i
was i think i think i was thinking of
the luther martin luther but one of them
was i can have a personal relationship
to god
was that was that luther yes okay so
forget about i don't know what the
protestant is
never but luther is the beginning of the
protestant reformation oh okay so then
there we go
yeah you're right okay so what luther
what luther is so luther is growing up
and spirituality is changing right and
it
so the the platonic elements are being
lost right and and
you know the supernatural is being sep
separated from the scientific
right and the renaissance is happening
and the scientific revolution is is sort
of
starting to percolate right and and
and and then the relationship to god is
becoming much more tenuous
but the text is becoming much much more
important the text
not the community not the church reading
the text
but the text itself and your individual
reading of the text is becoming
important right
and so all of that's coming together and
luther and luther
luther comes to the conclusion that
right and and part of it's because of
the way this gap is opened up that
there's nothing we can do
there's no way in which we participate
in our salvation there's no way in which
we do anything
that helps us community
human beings so i'm speaking as if i was
luther here these are not my beliefs
right but they're like human beings
right
can't get to god in any way so
his notion of the self has become so
like so enfolded
that the the sense of self deception has
become so profound and overwhelming
he thinks that anything and everything
we try to do just gets
folded back into this self-deception and
that we there's no way on our own we can
possibly escape it right
and and and so and that but that and
that
that's a reflection of course of how god
is now sort of becoming inaccessible
right he comes to the conclusion
that the only way we can be saved
is like by god
saving us completely from the outside
right
and this is what he means by by faith
alone and by scripture alone
right and what he means by that is god
acts through scripture
just the bible not the church god acts
through scripture
and that somehow transforms you and
frees you
and saves you that's how you get
salvation because salvation actually
means to heal
right um that's you know salve uh
healing potion right
and and so why why does this matter
so much well what it means is right it
means a lot of things
it means this is part of the final
divorce of
religion from any kind of rationality
luther calls reason a [ __ ] you know
obviously so you made a distinction
between logic and rationality yeah but
reason and rationality
yes yeah okay so luther calls reason a
[ __ ]
i i can't see augustine saying that
especially because of his respect for
plato and platinus right and
and and the fact that
you do not participate at all in your
salvation means
participatory knowing is irrelevant it's
irrelevant
right and this whole notion from the
axial age of
self-transcendence you can't you you're
incapable of self-transcendence
it's god's arbitrary act and notice also
what it means
you are in no way deserving of being
saved by god
there's nothing you did or could
possibly do
that would cause god to save you rather
than that person there
now notice how how terrifyingly sort of
absurd that makes
god i'm surprised that became popular
instead of just instead of
burning him oh well the thing you have
to remember right
is that luther is also you know he's
taking a stand against the catholic
church he's taking again
stand against its corrupt practices like
indulgence he's giving the german
princes it's only because the german
princes backed him
he's giving them a a new way of
organizing and identifying themselves in
opposition
political and economic opposition to the
catholic church so there's all these
extraneous factors that help
and there's also the fact right that
that luther
right is giving people
it's giving people a kind of authority
over their it's not authority in the
sense that they can do anything
but it's it's a sense like you said that
authority is the wrong word you talked
about they have luther is promising them
a direct personal relationship with god
because you don't have to you can't go
through the church
or right it's it's own god has to
directly reach into you
right now i i you can see why this is
destroying
the roles of participatory knowing
what it's it's exacerbating the fact
that i i i
now i'm not going through any
transformation god is saving me
and is he saving you arbitrarily so it
doesn't even matter if you know the
bible or read it
well ultimately it's god who's going to
lead you to the bible and lead you to
read the bible correctly
so that you will be saved so there's no
free will
well i i i don't know i'm not saying
what you believe i mean in
the lutheran model luther seems to have
this weird view that we are free to sin
but we're not free to do what's right
i mean i i i i i've talked to lutherans
about this
all you can do is is sin minimization
maybe i'm not even sure
[Laughter]
i'm not even sure that that's a real
possibility for him i mean this is part
of the debate he had with erasmus
because erasmus was still trying to with
his synergistic theology he was still
trying to
argue that we participated in our
salvation in some way but see
the the concern i have is notice what's
happening here right you know the
participatory perspectival
transformative stuff it's all in your
head it's all propositions all that
matters is asserting the right things
because that's all the love does the
love doesn't give you argument the love
just
i believe right so it's just a matter of
will right
so it's it's god's arbitrary will
arbitrary choice
and then you've got this arbitrary
response
right and and so a lot of the machinery
of meaning i think is being deeply
undermined
and i i i i'm particularly critical of
this and
this this gets me into hot water with
some christians because
i think all of that's quite destructive
i mean it's important because
like i said it it helps open up
the europe to you know at least a
non-catholic
way of life uh this kind of you know
willingness to challenge authority and
the the you know the the
the deep you know valuation of
propositional knowing it's going to also
help facilitate
science luther thinks so has his prose
definitely so i i want that in place but
we're concentrating on the genealogy so
i'm emphasizing that
the the the negative side of things you
see but what look look what luther is
teaching you
he's teaching you that you're worthless
you're empty inside
right and the only thing that can save
you
is unearned unearned positive
regard from
up above from up above that you have you
don't have any control over
you don't have any control of it and
it's currently so maybe it may not be
arbitrary but you just don't have
control over it
well it's arbitrary in the sense that
there's god has no reason for choosing
you over anybody else
or else or so why would god do that we
don't know i mean
it's mysterious and then you get endless
debates in christianity about whether or
not
god chose before the beginning of time
who which people are going to be saved
or not
predestination and whether he
predestined people to heaven or hell
and so there's there's endless attempts
and this is
why chris protestantism fragments and
fragments and fragments and fragments
endless attempts to try and resolve this
problem that don't get properly resolved
so i'm not going to try and do that
because the protestants haven't
succeeded on that project
but notice what's happening you get
endless fragmentation and in fact it's
it's still accelerating today so you get
this fragmentation
happening right you get the loss of the
participatory
and transformative knowing right you get
the so luther thinks and this is
important because he was a monk
luther thinks the monastery should be
shut down because what are people doing
there where they're trying to cultivate
wisdom
they're trying to engage in
self-transcendence they're practicing
spiritual exercises
well in luther's mind that's just pride
that's just sin
because human beings can't do anything
so the monastery's got to be shut down
so that's
the wisdom institutions of our culture
gets shut down
and you know the university in the
monastery the knowledge institution the
wisdom institutions used